hervé alors le sujet suivant va
illustrer complètement ce fait de midi
pyrénées
avant-hier à lille nous parlions du
picard le patois local est bien ici plus
encore les midi pyrénéens sont attachés
à l'occitan alors c'est une langue il
faut savoir d'une richesse
exceptionnelle en français par exemple
on dispose de trois de 30 mille mots et
bien en occitan cent soixante mille mots
donc pour cette langue très riche avec
au devant de la scène si vous êtes de
cette génération vous souvenez peut-être
des post soixante huitards qui dans le
larzac criaient gardarem lou larzac
c'est ainsi qu'on a peut-être découvert
l'occitan en tout cas une génération
c'est à ces cris qui résonnait face aux
militaires du plateau du larzac se
rappelle peut-être quelques souvenirs à
certains d'entre vous voici en tout cas
le reportage sur l'occitan de christophe
la rocca et olivier combe
c'était les années 70 l'époque de tous
les mouvements révolutionnaires en
aveyron un plateau convoité par les
militaires allaient offrir à l'occitan
le signal médiatique de la renaissance
avec un slogan aussi célèbre que
trompeur l'occident c'était la langue
officielle de ce conflit pour moi non
moi j'ai rarement entendu des paysans du
larzac
même les vrais ceux qu'on appelait les
pur porc parler il serait aujourd'hui
500 milles en midi pyrénées a parlé avec
fierté cette langue
jadis dévaloriser leur porte drapeaux
les fabulous troubadours
un duo qui alterne sans complexe
chansons en français et en occitan
you inattendue dont l'humour et la
modernité a dépassé les frontières au
point d'être l'une des références de la
presse la branche
on a trouvé l'exotisme chez nous des
milliards de tradition grande
littérature fantastique extrêmement
intéressante qui parle de la france le
de façon totalement décalé par rapport à
la culture française s'était réservé que
l'amérique fait on a découvert
l'amérique au quotidien l'héritage de la
vague occitane des années 70 concernent
surtout l'éducation en midi-pyrénées 5%
des enfants scolarisés bénéficie d'au
moins une initiation à la langue même
s'ils ne sont que 1000 à 1500 à suivre
un enseignement majoritairement en
occitan connaissez dans lesquels on
regrette les écoles associatives
occitane c'est une façon prendre
l'habitude tout simplement de jongler
entre deux langues éventuel manque de
culture
et ça c'est une habitude qui va servir
tout pour communiquer et même sur sa
demande notre 25ème bougie
allied d'accord que la jeunesse c'est
aussi vers elle que guillon européenne
surtout en finançant le doublage de
dessins animés elle affirme son soutien
ou leur priorité et la route injustement
cellule avec maurice andrieux il anime
chaque semaine sur france 3 une émission
en occitan est suivi par 70 mille
personnes et personne ne sait à quoi
rêvent aujourd'hui les autres jeunes du
stade le grand mot c'est une autonome
parce qu'il est vrai qu'il y à l'exemple
espagnol voisins il y à l'exemple
allemand et en espagne il est certain
que depuis la fin du franquisme
l'espagne a fait des progrès de
démocratie beaucoup plus importants que
l'état français aujourd'hui vraiment il
ya un intérêt par rapport à tout ce que
peut véhiculer cette langue et cette
culture
il ya surtout le souci de se dire bombay
on le fait en tant que créateur et en
tant que professionnel
alors oui le rêve politique des
occitanistes révolutionnaire est
aujourd'hui ultra minoritaire mais la
culture occitane elle est en pleine
expansion